sortie de la prostitution où il y a 13
ans Marie-Michelle Demeule dit avoir
vécu un total de 25000 agressions et la
désormais besoin de tout le soutien
autour d'elle dont celui de son petit
chien zombie c'est les clients qui m'ont
abusé les séquelles c'est c'est
super simple après avoir été vendu battu
par son proxénète Josh Juvet Jean
maintenant derrière les barreaux et
contre lequel et la portée plainte en
2014 elle déplore le manque de
sensibilisation à toute l'exploitation
sexuelle qui se déroule durant de grands
événements comme le Grand Prix de
Formule 1 je pense que le problème les
politiques je voudrais que les peines
soient plus sévères en matière de
proxénétisme j'aimerais que les
bracelets électroniques soient admis en
matière de proxénétisme j'aimerais que
l'IVAC reconnaissent le choc
post-traumatique tu veux dire que
c'est ridicule les montants qui sont
versés victime Grand Prix ou pas celle
qui s'adonnent à la prostitution semble
de plus en plus jeune au fil des ans
cette année nous avons au moins 50% des
femmes qui nous ont contacté ou des
jeunes filles à la clé qui sont dans la
tranche d'âge de 15 ans à 35 ans c'est
quand même énorme les centres jeunesse
avec leurs clientèle vulnérables et les
réseaux sociaux resteraient encore des
lieux privilégiés par les proxénètes la
mairesse de Montréal Valérie plante
souligne qu'il faut qu'une
sensibilisation soit faite dans les bars
les hôtels et lors de festivals on aime
ça faire la fête mais on ne se réjouit
pas et on n'acceptera pas de la
prostitution et la traite des femmes en
mai dernier le travail de Marie-Michelle
Desmeules en tant que survivante
d'exploitation sexuelle a été applaudi
au Sénat c'est pas ça qui est important
pour moi
moi c'est qu'on change les choses une
cause qui selon elle devrait l'animer
pour le reste de ses jours ici Gabriel
prout Radio-Canada Montréal